filmé en fumée produits mender site a
les poches vides il faut des bunkers
face à la cité récupère des bunkers
siffle même dansé jaune comme l'équipe
des lakers c'est la cata 2500 banger
sale guerre voisine et un kilo gender
c'est la rate à 2505 guerre c'est à dire
voici les 1 kg de melzer
mais jimmy jim enders que des pleins
phares pour des bunkers ces amours là
c'est du mend heures
alors là ça a été un buzz énorme chance
que j hadid
elle était vraiment pas contente
apparemment la mannequin voilà qu'il a
plus de 1 hier marie saint fils qui a
reçu une menace de mise en demeure pour
avoir utilisé l'image de la mannequin à
la partager sur son instinct jci plutôt
que de passer par des voies légales
régler ça entre femmes je te propose un
octogone sans règle tous les coups sont
permis
à la rigueur un combat dans la boue
effet l'inra avait de fort boyard fort
larbitre odjija pas moyen de jci fais
pas ta katadji genre ont tenu chadelle
tu dit ça voilà bien sûr reprise layana
qu'à moi et c'est vrai que moi pour moi
je trouve que pour elle c'est
exceptionnel ça lui fait une pub bien
sûr sur wii kelly
si je peux me permettre dit d'y aller de
ses le mannequin c'est un métier et moi
je peux comprendre qu'à un moment donné
elle pense qu'on se moque de son métier
que quelqu'un mais ceux ci c'est pour
moi c'est une imitation d'une top model
et en plus elle le fait à sa manière de
façon rigolote moi j'ai rien contre ce
qu'elle fait mais je peux comprendre
aussi la partie de djihad ide qui se dit
mais elle se fout de ma gueule l'ancien
mobilité gasquet lui reprochent à leurs
proches et le droit à l'image est
parfaite elle veut juste de l'oseille
parce qu'elle a mis une photo d'elle
alors et communique breivik ce nom mais
là c'est juste une question d'argent
c'est une question de droit et ménages à
eric besson il s'étonnant elle dit pas
ça n'a pas besoin d'eux et elle dit pas
ça c'est pas le lot zaïdite vous dit des
bêtises à dijon tél ils ont les moyens
c'est le moyen de l'emmerder elle a
trouvé lui juridique pour l'arrêt
selon me faut pas d'oseille a les pleins
dé la saga non je pense qu'elle devrait
plutôt s'en prendre aux personnes qui
ont géré le défilé chanel à la
fashion-week parce que c'est quand même
un truc de ouf que pour un événement
pareil quand on sait l'organisation sa
demande les stars qui défilent que marie
saint philippe que moi je trouve ça
fascinant qu'elle arrive à ce à marcher
en plus aussi longtemps parce qu'on n'a
même pas mis toute la séance mais elle
marche hyper longtemps sur le tessin est
exactement hyper longtemps il ya des
gens qui interviennent sur un match de
foot et tout ça donc c'est pas c'est pas
la sécurité parce que moi à mettre en
cause il n'y a pas là c'est que c'est
comme s'ils s'y risée mondiale prenait à
marc-antoine le bret parce qu'ils
limitent voilà elle a imité une
mannequin c'est juste une personne qui
défilent avec des assurances on peut
descendre à temps et qu'elle se prenne
pas cependant sérieux c'était drôle là
pas ridiculiser un peu d'humour ont
franchement c'est pas mettre les rênes
chrono très vite moi je suis un peu
quand même des tendances à suivre
kelly quand même parce que nous c'est
sûr ça nous fait marrer mais quand tu as
bossé c'est quelque chose qui va durer
trois minutes un défilé comme ça s'émeut
regardée dans le monde entier ont fait
ton boulot de ce que nous avons fait
réel cela fait je comprends que cela
fasse pas rire ça pète sont allés vers 6
ans clôt le débat là dessus